before we [ __ ] on the American
government and back-alley politics and
all that why don't we talk about
accountability give me seven hot takes
on [ __ ] they can do everybody really
excited about this conversation with
especially you're listening we're fill
it we're recording filming this prior
but you are listening to this podcast as
this book is coming out food fix is out
today please go to your local bookstores
or amazon.com or however you roll and
the gentleman who wrote it is with us
here today so mark why don't you tell
the Vayner nation who you are and what
you do and then why you wrote this book
and then we're gonna we're gonna Jam me
like Who I am the means of life my yes
yes sir okay I'm dr. Mark Hyman I'm a
physician I trained in family medicine
but have been practicing functional
medicine for 25 years which is the
science of health and how to find the
root causes of what's wrong with people
and get people better by dealing with
those it's not throwing medicine at it
it's not it's actually the science
fellas how do you create health the
traditional medicine is focused on
diagnosing disease and treating it with
a drug usually or surgery it's a pill
for ever yeah functional medicine is
about the science of creating health by
understand the imbalances in the system
in order the toxins algae's microbes
stress poor diet that's driving
imbalances and one of the things you
need that you don't get the right food
nutrients balance of light air water
connection love meeting all that is is
really how we create health and it's
phenomenal for chronic disease and I'm
also the head of strategy and innovation
for the Cleveland Clinic Center for
functional medicine Everett in 12 New
York Times bestsellers I'm the host of
the doctors pharmacy podcast which is a
top 200 podcast and I and I'm really on
a mission to help get the to the end of
the of needless suffering through
addressing chronic disease through
functional medicine and fixing the food
system because you know I've I've been
sitting in my office for thirty years
seeing patient after patient who's sick
with chronic disease this caused mostly
by food and it's like being in a boat
that's sinking with a bucket trying to
bail it and I finally asked why are we
seeing so
people who are sick its food and why do
we have the food we have it's the food
system and why do we have the food
system it's our food policies and why do
we have our food policies it's the food
industry's influence on policy
there's 187 lobbyists for every member
of Congress it's the number-one lobby
group by far which is the food now
against trees so that's really you know
how I've come to what I'm doing now
which is really focusing on food it's
medicine and food as the solution is so
many of our global crises you know it's
funny because I'm sitting with you I'm
gonna paint a picture for everybody's
listening I'm sitting with you and over
your shoulder is a wonderful team member
of mine on who's worked with us for a
while who's he's doing his best to not
have his head fully fall off his body
because it's you know you're talking and
it's been it's something that he's
talked to me about personally without
knowing exactly you know he's talked
about his father and turkeys from Turkey
he's a great kid and obviously you're
you're a big buyer of this and it's fun
for me because when I talk about
business I talked about don't fix the
sick sink fix the well yes and so this
is you know much like I invested in
Facebook one second into seeing it when
soon on first came to me is like hey I
want to like really help you because I
care about you and you're doing
everything wrong and I want you to do
this kind of [ __ ] like I'm fascinated by
the 187 lobbyists of one I'm fascinated
by the old system of life yeah
government's life yeah media government
life how today with social media
everyone's blaming social media for our
problems yet what social media is doing
is exposing our truths true and yours is
a dark in a life side yeah the dark and
light side because it's a mirror yeah
and so you know it's it's really funny
you were literally just going through
your set up here
you know I see sign on in the corner I'm
thinking about you know we're an
election year I my profile has risen so
much that I get an uncanny amount of
direct messages of like I think I'm
really passionate about insecurity and
and like happiness and I literally just
to
this is really fun it's really exciting
for me for you because if I'm hearing
your narrative right the amount of
buyers of what you were putting down 25
30 years ago
in comparison to today yeah but more
importantly in comparison to today the
infrastructure of communication in an
Internet world yeah
which is the real actual counter to 187
to one I'm just like literally sitting
here starting to get goosebumps of like
okay
this is really gonna be a big [ __ ]
deal in 30 years because we're in half
time right now yeah you're free for you
this is yeah yeah in your paradigm yeah
the last you know again 30 years and and
so I said it you laughed you have very
few buyers you have a lot more buyers
now yeah and non buyers are curious or
financially bested interest to put their
head in the sand or scared I'm a scared
guy like for example I'm a really funny
guy it's like if I didn't have to go to
doctor ever again in my life in any
shape or form that would be best for me
and like I'd rather give up those 23
years of life then go to the doctor
that's how much I hate it I mean great
transparent you can also be the CEO your
own health and oh listen there's nothing
you're gonna say that isn't wrong and
I'm about to say everything that's wrong
like I know that to be true because it's
the other parallel of my life where I
see it in Reverse in other areas so
nonetheless with all that setup from you
and then my little rant here yeah let me
think in a little bit of a different
direction because you have me excited
what's what's what's going on in this
macro converse like are you like as a
human how old are you how are you think
I am
you are you said 25 30 years you're 53
60 beautiful all right where you are
right now
are you pumped because you're like [ __ ]
something that like was so [ __ ] I decide
you know way I'm so excited because the
food industry is so screwed up right
it's causing six out of ten Americans to
be sick it's bankrupting our country you
know one out of every two Medicare
whenever every $2 in our mandatory
federal spending in five years will be
for Medicare which is mostly veronik
disease we're
seeing climate change being affected by
food is the number one cause of climate
change we're seeing poverty social
injustice mental illness academic
challenges in kids depression even
national security issues because kids
are too too fat or unfit to fight these
are all in part caused by food food food
industry is the number one cause of
climate change so as I look at all these
separate problems I'm so excited because
if food was the cause it's also the
killer hundred percent and we have the
power to change all that I see this all
the time I practice where we take people
who have heart failure diabetes early
kidney failure
fatty liver all these problems and we
can reverse it with food but we can't do
that with the current food system we
have it has to change and it's okay
quick example of why I'm so excited last
few days Burger King launched an ad that
showed a big whopper that went moldy
over thirty four days and the punchline
was there's no artificial preservatives
now it's still a whopper it's still not
healthy for you but the idea that it's a
country fast-food company would know you
said it right the first time a badger
country company would lead with we're
cleaning up our food because the
consumers are driving the behavior we're
seeing nestles doing different things
we're seeing Kellogg's saying no more
glyphosate your cereal is saying General
Mills no we're gonna move a million
acres into regenerative agriculture
which will bring back the soil and
preserve preserve the land and actually
help us prevent climate change it's
powerful when you see these companies is
a country of currency this is an
entrepreneurial capitalistic country and
the reason I asked you the question I
appreciate your answer and I was hoping
it is because you must be pumped it's
similar to me like in 25 years when
entrepreneurs and business people think
being happy and kind is better than
having a boat and being a dick face
honestly I'm actually projecting you
know what makes people's dick faces
often what they're eating yes because it
inflames their brain literally the
science is so clear that mental illness
even violence in prisons you give
violent prisoners healthy food in
prisons the violent crime goes down by
56 percent and you get my vitamin it
goes down by an 80 percent let's make
this fun
and let me take this in a couple
different places because you're gonna do
plenty of other podcasts you have your
own you're gonna be able to beat that
drum I want to take this in a little bit
of a different direction meaning a
framework that I want to have this combo
in talk to me about this is rigid give
me five to seven bullets that needs to
happen at the micro before we go into
the systemic change that you're
passionate about because I heard you sis
you know system system says yes we'll go
on a summon ask you because I'm curious
yeah that's more me for everybody's
listening cuz I'm fascinated s give me
seven to 12 hot takes bullets of
questions or statements that every
single person that's listening right now
should think about on a personal level
that they can achieve because you know
humans when they hear 187 lobbyists
about immediately going to [ __ ]
change it anyway yeah well that's yes so
let's talk about accountability
absolutely before we [ __ ] on the
American government and back-alley
politics and all that why don't we talk
about accountability give me seven hot
takes on [ __ ] they can do absolutely so
so in food fix my book how to save our
health our economy our communities on
our planet one by the time it's it's
called food fix it's not called food
apocalypse because it's focused on what
we can do and what you can do and yes we
need the political change but on a
personal level you can focus your diet
to become more aspirational towards
being a regenitive now what the heck is
that what is that I like that sounds all
the framework so regenerative
agriculture as a wave grunt food
it grows higher quality food that build
a soil with organic matter that draws
carbon out of the atmosphere literally
most of the carbon a third of the carbon
that's in the atmosphere today came from
the destruction of our soil we can put
it back in the soil that's the rain for
us so it'll help us with conserve water
we're losing you know water scarcity is
a huge thing around the world and we're
seeing floods and droughts that can be
solved by fixing the soil through these
methods it actually can reduce the use
of pesticides fertilizers and and all
these harmful things it's better for the
animals because they're grazing around
and increases about diversity our
pollinators are dying 75% are lost bees
and butterflies that can be rebuilt
through regenerative agriculture so if
you seek out foods from farms that are
using these methods
and you can do it at your local farmers
market you can join a community
supported agriculture in your community
you can go online and find regenerative
meat for example from places like
Mariposa ranch where you can get a pound
of meat for an average of 8 bucks a
pound which per serving is probably
about the same or less than a McDonald's
hamburger and you can start to look for
sources and you can't be perfect and
nobody's perfect I'm not perfect but
being a specialist in perfect currently
where my favorite is powerful
I see I'm most imperfect about how much
I work I need but the reason I work
sorry when you put in your body food
wise give me like a twizzler give me
something to get ever never learn never
happens I scream a couple of times
digging eyes let me ask you a question
when you eat I say what are you like
doing it at home cuz I'm outside the
funny story sells me so I was at a
medical conference at Harvard and Tufts
and the Dean of the tough school of
nutrition yes the former CEO of Whole
Foods one of the leading sort of
scientists in food as medicine was there
and we and we were we the five of us
like we're like buddies and we're like
alright we're gonna sneak out for this
conference and we're gonna go get gelato
and I'm sitting there on the corner
gelato and this woman comes up to the
doctor I'm like oh [ __ ] I think most
people break that you know it's funny I
in real food right why don't be I don't
eat industrial food so in other words if
it's some product was made in a factory
that's industrial food that's not real
food I generally won't eat it but I will
eat sweet sometimes I'll have you know a
cake or I'll have a chocolate or I'll
have ice cream enough of a sweet tooth
that's the battle right yeah but I but I
it's I'm pretty when you think is when
you regulate your biology you don't
really want that stuff anymore you crave
like vegetables and it sounds crazy but
yes you can gray vegetables I love that
that's always been an easy one for me so
so those are those are some simple fixes
and then you can help end food waste
food waste is crazy we waste a pound of
food for every person every day in this
country it's 40% of our food and
globally it's 40%
it's the the food that would need to be
grown on a landmass the size of China
over two trillion dollars of waste and
that's not the worst part how does one
do that socially the worst part is we
throw our scraps and our food the waste
into landfills we throw it into
landfills where it creates methane
that's 25 times more potent a greenhouse
gas than carbon dioxide it's a huge
contributor to climate change exactly so
as that can do listen tan you can if you
lives in the city you can get a little
in apartment composter where you throw
your food scraps and it turns it into
this incredible humus soil that you can
give to your local farmers market I'm
sure the farmers will take it and if you
have not here that's annoying a [ __ ] you
know we have our building there's a
composting thing so in San Francisco
it's mandatory you get a fine if you
don't compost and Frances mandatory you
go to jail or you're gonna find if you
don't copy us a message sounds good
yeah jails good huh obviously we need to
get into like jail thing a lot about I
think we need more dictate like I'm not
kidding yes your dictatorship I think a
lot of what America at this maturity of
an empire is caught with why we're so
extreme and left and right is like there
needs to be thoughtful jailing yeah well
you know in in in America yes exactly
FDA we're supposed to recycle to yes
many people do not just they don't and
because nothing works when there's no
ramification promised you something
right now if everybody got a ticket like
a DM all of a sudden with like a bill
that like you had to pay like a parking
ticket because it was easy to see that
you didn't recycle in your building
their funny feeling people would I'm
sure the reason nobody cares about
privacy you know my tech world people
like a society now we talk about
privacy's cuz nobody's money is getting
taken away forever so that's why you
keep throwing around your information
there's no actual ream ramifications
well cuz no consequence there are
they're just more invisible right yes
they're free wells being usurped by
targeted digital but his strategies yes
because I what happened last election
you know we
talk about that like you're sick you you
they didn't know you didn't pull it like
you like when you watch CNBC when you
watch CNN or Fox you're making that
choice like you're mr. true is it true
but there's a lot of stealth stuff going
on I mean where's three billion data
points that these are these companies
that are selling and purchasing it and
selling it to digital marketers just
fine to sell you shoes but it's
different when it's trying to persuade
you to join a rally but it's not trying
to persuade you let's explain if you're
going in a feed and somebody knows that
it has data around what you've been
doing and it presents something to you
you know that right
but if you but if your digital feed is
for example like what Cambridge
analytical did which is digital targeted
political marketing then you target your
personality weaknesses that makes you do
things based on your fear and they know
exactly how to manipulate you based on
your personality profiles and you think
you're acting out it free well that's
the part I have a problem with and the
food is but real quick on that yeah one
could argue that that's about every
single thing that happens period I mean
then you have a major problem with the
insurance business right completely the
whole thing based on fear
it's true but you must also hate
parenting oh you must be the biggest
descendant a parenting period because
the entire structure is 90% for your
based well I don't think that's a good
way to raise your kids is terrifying my
but I think what's really interesting is
I think instead of going into this
portal that were not in control well we
need to have a bigger conversation about
is accountability yes we can't if you're
selling food fix yes
then you better really also in equal
parallel understand that targeting like
we're talking about one in the same game
right in the fact of like the unlock to
all this actually is starting to get
into an ecosystem where we do feel in
control yeah absolutely but some people
it's hard if you I mean I'm working
Cleveland and I talked to this young
woman who lived in an East Cleveland
very poor area I there were no grocery
stores anywhere near her her mother saw
her you know her hand and alcohol get
their lamb limps amputated from diabetes
she had that she wanted to feed her kids
healthy food she had take two buses I
was an hour each way just to buy
vegetables respect that I mean that's
the challenge and and they're all they
have around their neighborhood is
processed food and soda they're
specifically targeted by the food
industry it's really insidious thing
about that you know what my head just
went on that for a fruitful conversation
it's so interesting that we talk about
how businesses are being incentivized to
follow consumer behavior like my brain
I'm an entrepreneur and I heard that I'm
like whoo I'm gonna I want to open a
fresh market they're like this is a
really interesting conversation about
like the right balance of policy versus
entrepreneurship and it all leads just
education
it's just macro awareness like what I'm
so passionate about of what you're doing
they're both in your pocket this is like
what we're doing right now it's just
awareness right like we're do that like
it's crazy how like placebo or like
awareness like I'm like feeling weird to
even drink this coffee drink our coffee
but actually I'm saying it in a good way
like I get the feedback from a lot of
people like I'm listening to you over
and over and I'm actually now not
enjoying negative people around me and
I'm like [ __ ] that's what I need to do
for myself around my week like if I just
kept listening to you I would like
that's what that's real-life action
right like to me it's like how do we get
things to actually happen actually
happen and I actually think that I mean
how do we gonna be able to change your
behavior I think good intent people like
you and I think a lot about making
something good happen right it's just
you know it's just our DNA of the lock
of the DNA draw yeah we want it it feels
good
yeah the admiration the legacy like it's
the behavior that I understand I have my
own slight version of it in different
place I think we think a lot about
systemic scale right we spend time
thinking about systems I'm listening to
you like if she doesn't have access like
I get it ironically what I'm proposing
for debate and conversation is what if
cuz we've watched that happen for the
last 70 80 years that American
conversation around systemic yeah and
I'm like hmm I wonder if we also really
start thinking about on an individual
basis level two we have to I mean it's
individual but it's also structural
right for 60 percent of the calories in
America are ultra processed food that
kill 11 million people a year is because
the government is funding the growth of
those crops corn soy but and we in turn
in the process I think 187 versus 1 if
we started dis purple
focusing on it by the way that's right
and the Burger King talked about that
whopper until the customer started yeah
that's what I'm saying that's why I'm
excited because I think the individuals
making change in their life and having
that voice drives businesses to change
their products that seem old about they
don't give a [ __ ]
they just want to do what the customer
wants that's right that's why it's so
empowering in this book because people
actually can do a lot of things that
drive the marketplace that drive what
food companies are doing that drive
their own health to be better and their
own communities their own family
underrated terrible thing all of us are
doing like something kind of unusual
like you're in this world like you mean
like a oh you think this is decent but
we're getting like what's a thematic
that you're like for example I'm very
under educating this but like all the
new like bars healthy about plants
plant-based meats yeah we are we hear
that the cows are the equivalent of the
atom bomb destroying the planet with
their methane burps and yeah and the
whole factory farming which is true and
that should be banned yeah yeah and the
alternative is plant-based means
impossible burger beyond me yes and
they're both a little bit different but
you know we think we're doing a good
thing but you so for example dissect
impossible burger one it's GMO soy so
it's grown away that Destructo so just
for your rant and everyone's gonna make
fun of me and be mad at me but that's
when you just shook your head on that
you know this to be true you just
thinking what he's saying is interesting
yeah beyond me right yeah they're both
highly processed foods so so you're down
on those people let me explain why no no
by the way I know you're going to it I'm
gonna allow you to even though I like to
interrupt you are you're you're you're
down you're down on those two things
I I am down on industrial processed food
it's those two those two are and I mean
headline is a little
because it's it's pea protein and it's a
little bit different than the GMO soy
but the GMO soy is grown away that's
destructed at the environment that
destroys a soil that puts glyphosate
which is extremely toxic causes cancer
and destroyed your microbiome into the
food and it has 47 novel proteins that
have never been tested in humans it's
it's it's got a strange formula there's
nothing but I here 47 never tests on
humans I'm already like that and I'm
like and then they're promoting as a
health food if you want to not eat me
and you want to try once in a while fine
it's not gonna kill you but if you make
it a staple there's 110 times the amount
of glyphosate in an impossible burger
then would be required to destroy the
microbiome of animals and glyphosate
around them it back to a man go ahead up
which is basically a weed killer then
you got in your burger and that amount
is real harmful effects and it does
reduce the amount of climate change
contribution compared to a factory farm
burger but if you look at regenerative
burgers which is cows that are grass
finished and grown in certain ways that
restore the land restore everything Irie
gently raised burger based on a
lifecycle analysis of both of those
would reduce carbon by three and a half
kilos of carbon per burger versus the
impossible worker adds three and half
kilo so you got the one meat burger to
offset the plant-based burger in terms
of conversations what is it
we generally raise burger yes yeah which
is amazing grass-fed but grown away that
actually restores the soil restores that
you mentioned that the cost of that
product is not there you can get it much
cheaper yes there now it's it's not as
prevalent it can be scaled in fact the
UN said that if we do this type of
Agriculture and we take 2 million of the
five million degraded hectares of land
around the world and turn into
regenerative agriculture which will cost
300 billion dollars which is less than
we spend in Medicare on diabetes every
year and abates in military spends the
entire world for 60 days that we could
stop climate change for 20 years just
simply by doing that form of Agriculture
so we we if we buy those things we're
gonna be pushing and that's why I mean
Nestle's and who's stopping the growth
of regenerative like who's nobody is
growing like crazy
Nestle known General Mills they're all
pushing this really this is just a
matter of time or always just a matter
of time this is
this is going to happen they're silly
you care on an individual basis right
like you're you care for the ones like
me at 44 it's like hey the six year olds
are gonna benefit from this because it's
gonna be the thing wake up you can get
some real benefits from it if you get on
board I mean we have 60 harvests left of
food according to the heart you went
because of the way we're destroying the
soil we've lost most of our topsoil
it's huge contributor to climate change
it can all be fixed by choosing to buy
foods and driving the marketplace with
your choices towards her generator
question yeah I'm innocent I communicate
one thing that I find really fascinating
I like it do you feel like I think about
this a lot do you feel like you're
excited because there's a lot of things
that are people are thinking about and
if you can use the human on the other
side that's listening right now if she
or he is excited about climate change
that you can use that as the gateway for
them to it can be climate change it can
be their own their own health it could
be caring about social justice to be
caring about our economy give a [ __ ] you
just want them to be better I want
people to understand the situation we're
in and take action and realize how
powerful they are to make a difference
but also how they need to use their
their fork and vote with their fork they
need to vote with their voice they need
to vote with their wallet need to vote
with their vote and I think people are
apathetic but we have so much power
like you said Burger King doesn't give a
[ __ ] about taking the crap out of your
food but they care consumer cares they
should like people like like when I say
they should they should but like you're
asking people to do things that you
wouldn't do like people care about their
kid more than somebody else's kid it's
real life it's human another point when
you were talking cuz when you don't want
to do [ __ ] you're looking for excuses so
that's good I don't want to eat like
actually I don't mind I'm actually I
like like good food like healthy food so
I'm a little bit lucky I just need to be
disciplined I'm just like a picker and
get ridiculous sometimes let me ask you
a question one of the things that I get
fascinated by is when you were talking I
was like ooh there it is and what you
said was like look if you want it a
couple of times it's not gonna kill you
which we love to hear right
occasionally and what is a lot of times
and like once a week once a month once a
year talk to me about something we
should consistently eat the reverse what
is a great thing that you can never eat
too much of go well is there such a
thing where's that we human have to be
broken down an 8 20 pounds of broccoli
you'd probably get sick and your calling
would stop up I mean it's all depends on
one shot one shot somebody can have a
big gulp in one shot right that's 750
calories you want to eat seven everybody
knows that broccoli is 21 cups of
broccoli good luck with that our
vegetables just like yeah that's
unlimited I say you get unlimited
refills you can eat all the vegetables
you want until you can't eat anymore and
you'll never get into trouble god I
really like that I really like
vegetables a lot yeah it's powerful
that's why I have a little bit different
because of the amount of sugar yeah
fruit you don't want to unlimited
amounts of fruit I mean unless you're an
athlete an unlimited fruit is there
berries berry series are good cuz
they're low in sugar or they're high in
phytochemicals or super nutritionally
dense and I think you know we're in this
moment in time where we have so many
crises there's so many silos and there's
so many problems and people feel
disempowered you know there's climate
change and there's chronic disease and
there's the economic issues and the
social justice issues and all these
problems environmental issues and all
they were linked by food and that's
where we have so much leverage that we
can actually use to change the system
both on our own lives and our families
and our kitchens in our communities but
also acting acting politically why do
you think the gay marriage is now legal
why do you think there's civil rights
and women's rights widen abolition
happen preach it because people cared
about it wasn't something that starred
in Congress and and it in Congress never
starts in Congress it never saw defense
that's right so exactly humans yeah
humans don't bother me what they're like
so I understand humans nobody I mean I
understand it yeah like I think our
biggest weakness for get before you get
the food get a relationship with
judgment which will actually lead you to
under
food yes our relationship with judgment
yeah I don't a lot of politicians aren't
capable of doing anything else yeah
their career politicians and if they get
voted out they're scared yeah like I
understand that's logical no different
than every other person listening right
now we have to make it in their
self-interest by having the voter and
their constituency set us speak out
that's based on yes a hundred percent I
mean there's not using right
the only 18 to 24 year olds have never
voted never voted do you know how many
of them are not gonna vote right now
that tweet everyday political stuff yeah
do you know in November how devastated
it's anybody that gives a [ __ ] about
kids voting not gonna be the kids
turnout is gonna be non-existent yeah we
need to change that I mean that I mean
just we have the right to vote which is
a rare thing in the world I mean
physically that sentence isn't doing
[ __ ] we've been doing that for 40 years
oh I know no doctor I think this is
really the point here because I'm like
sitting here and being very selfish I'm
like how am I gonna use use talking and
sit on in the corner of my eye right now
as a catalyst for me to get
disproportionate better I've gotten
better I can get a lot better he's
talking to me about like the sheep's I
[ __ ] sleep in and [ __ ] airplanes
alike and I'm like I believe but like he
sits here and I'm like he's right
without knowing anything he walks out
I'm go to my next meeting I'm like he's
a hundred [ __ ] person I know it
because he's looking and I'm not looking
it's like anything else but we have two
individuals like you and I who are lucky
enough to amass audiences have to have
more thoughtful debates about things
like I promise you one thing more than I
know that the Sun will come up tomorrow
telling eighteen-year-olds that they are
lucky for the right to vote is a no-no I
agree let's stop let's start punching
them in the face but they care about
their future they care about climate
change they care about they care about
it on Twitter but they don't want to go
and register we need to have this
conversation like we do you think I want
to die I surely don't and I'd like to be
dramatically more educated about the
[ __ ] you're talking about because I'm
fundamentally comments' sitting in this
room that you can extend my life by
seven and a half years if I want respect
so like we need to get when are we
eventually gonna actually figure this
out and understand how this really works
which is you have to do the other weird
we're trying to do for the last 50 years
is not working when we go into guilt hey
kids
feel guilty there's countries I was
putting the Soviet write everything up I
go starving kids in China but I get it I
was born in the Soviet Union very easy
for me to connect to my incredible
luxury of being able to vote and I have
I have but like I do many other things
that I should be doing that I don't I
think the question that we need to start
talking about both in food and we've got
a little more macro here is what is the
new off what's our off-speed pitch
because what we've separated into is two
camps that no question if we mix the two
there's a lot of good in it yeah and
there's a lot of bad in both and like
what's the New Age way to like like
you've been doing this for 35 years the
consumer is starting to get you
optimistic it never was gonna come from
the systemic change good news 187 to 1
is about to be 213 to 1 and you know it
and I know it so how are you - [ __ ]
Hackett I I actually am working on that
I have an elite group of Washington
insiders who help bono launch the one
campaign which got 87 billions in
appropriations for AIDS in Africa where
most lawmakers didn't give a crap about
that and they did it through being
Washington insiders and knowing and
immaculee how to manipulate lawmakers I
hate to say that but they know what they
need they know what's in their
constituency they know what they're
gonna vote for they know what they're
not gonna vote for they know what their
their pain points are they know what
their issues are excited about and so
it's literally a very deliberate
strategies and nonprofit and it's a and
it's a havoc so I started a lobby group
because yeah I'm sick and tired of like
having only the good guys be sitting
around talking on the outside and not on
the inside in fact I was with the guy
who was the head of the Obama
administration's food policy Sam Kass
and he said Marco was striking to me was
every day people would come in from the
lobby groups and they would have these
briefing books with 50 different
regulations and legislative acts already
written in all the justification and
they would give it to the lawmakers and
they would know they wouldn't be having
time to figure it all out so they would
go kind of follow along with it and he
said the whole time where there wasn't
one good guy who came in and said you
know we want to put the food system and
do this an advocacy group for the good
guys so that's what we're doing and
and I'm okay within the system you you
have to do both you have to drive a
grassroots effort which we're doing
through a non-profit the food fix
campaign and we're doing a 20x action
and you know it's a fool's errand maybe
I'm not going to say you know with
shouting wails but I I can't not help it
because I see the massive nature the
problem I see Mike his future threatened
I see the threaten the threat it's like
an I feel like I'm on the beach and
there's a tsunami coming everything a
sunt I'm like hey wake up everybody you
know we got to get on this why do you
think that it's so hard for people to
believe those macro doomsday things like
once it's hard it's hard because it's
not really doesn't feel real like you're
out it feels good yeah if somebody's
listening can do this for me
can somebody pull up the articles that
clearly must have been a newspaper I'm
trying to think back when is I need to
understand the Black Plague more I bring
it up a lot I'd like to understand what
the articles were the only cop I can
think of that I've had conversations
about this was Hitler right I've talked
to people old enough
who or who've studied enough who can
really like physically show me the
articles written a black it's not that
big of a deal it's gonna be okay and
then it did it like I think what people
need is a black-and-white example but I
hope because the you know during World
War two this country came together to
fight a common enemy it was sort of like
the we're great at it's what yeah but it
did an interesting way you know all the
Americans had to turn their lights out
yeah dark yep all the Americans had to
ration food all the Americans had to
have Victory Gardens forty percent of
the food produced in America was from
Victory Gardens the Americans gave so
much in terms of sacrifice and reduction
in their material benefits and their
efforts and their money to help save the
world and they did it because they saw
this common threat an enemy we don't see
that stick here for a second though they
also saw that their son was going to
France yes we have to figure out how to
make this selfish this Nobel's nobody
turned off their light they turned off
their lights cuz John went to [ __ ]
war yeah and they were scared buckless
that their son was gonna die yeah like
we have to as a as a good guys we have
to figure out how to make this [ __ ]
selfish yeah because this selfless act
is gonna play out on Twitter and
everyone's gonna look at everybody else
and not vote well it's not like like I'm
a million percent of my audience is
under 30 and 80% of them are not
registered to vote right now Straight
Talk yeah I'll get get on it guys get on
it [ __ ] you thirty thousand dollars and
how many guys this room or register over
let's go honest here there we go I
appreciate the ah yes there you go right
like I love you I love you for not
raising it and by the way no judgment
this is back to judgment I have no
judgment I have no job zero I think we
have to us saying to them get on it
listen here is your job you're a digital
marketing I appreciate this it's what
I'm doing right now in the micro what
I'm doing right now is actually what I'm
asking for all of us to debate more me
making this conversation about this yeah
is the punch line which is like I know
the guilt doesn't work no no fear does
fear works fear works and I also know
that in for me what I love about you and
I've admired from afar and why listen
you you you're a [ __ ] speaker we
looked at a million names I like people
who populate information like I like
that you're a human media company I like
that do you do a book I do books I'm a
digital guy yeah I like to do podcast
where where I'm where I'm conversating
with you because I respect you is a
hundred comments a [ __ ] you Gary yeah
like you talk about people like I'd I'd
love to cry in my Bentley I don't have
money I'm like because you don't know
what crying in a Bentley looks like
right like you you have to change your
perspective yeah I spend my time trying
to figure out the off-speed pitch the
people I admired the most you included
that are out there are thrown fast balls
yeah and I'm trying to figure out how to
slow slow ball add to the repertoire
because what I know is that we're
talking down and it's not adding and
results you know I make sense yeah for
sure like I'm trying to use this moment
like through our two energies yes maybe
populate something in my thought here
you listen for you like what's our
off-speed pitch okay you know cuz we
need it cuz
we you know what's gonna happen well
like everybody everybody knows people
and their family and their life who are
sick who are sick from food and who get
it in or suffering and that's where the
pain is for most people whether it's
mental illness I mean two days ago one
of my wife's good friends just committed
suicide and and you know these you know
we see for example in studies that kids
who can switch from junk food to healthy
food who were teenagers reduced suicide
by a hundred percent and suicides a
third leading cause of death in
teenagers so so like we know there's so
much suffering out there and if people
got the connection between food like all
these issues it's a big deal why are we
having so much conflict and divisive
this cuz it screws up our brains and our
ability to actually have the adults in
the room our reptile brain is the
reactive impulsive fighting aggressive
brain that is not getting moderated by
the adults in the room when there's a
diet that's causing inflammation in the
brain this is a scientific fact I
believe so so there's this on so many
levels
because of all this I'm listening to you
are you more concerned about the
Impossibles and the and the ball candy
the bar now look like no stick with me
for a second it's not that we're picking
on them let me ask let me ask you a
different way the trend of the last
decade where foods are positioned to
look healthy but are just as unhealthy
as like I would argue listening to you
I'm like oh wow he must be more upset at
a kind bar than a Snickers bar because
the brand of then I'm not let's not just
use those two I'm just saying there's a
very clear movement you know I decided
to start losing I'm by I got very my
first move was exercise and at least
understand calories that was that basic
six years ago for me and now I'm
evolving and and what was fun through
that journey is like oh these are tricky
they look super healthy but those are
the same numbers I see on the stuff
that's the shittiest of [ __ ] we're
supposed to me right that to me is
actually a very interesting current
state of the market where I think
there's a lot of people listening right
now that feel pretty decent about their
choices ya know a Whole Foods you get a
lot of junk I mean right it's got less
preservatives less toxic and green
your [ __ ] book cover actually gonna
be full of sugar and starch and things
that really make people not great I mean
this is certainly better than what
you're eating in you know traditional
grocery store but it's not it's not
necessarily a health food you know
that's where this is getting interesting
what in the old world like what is I
love history it's the one group like
when you when you or maybe you haven't
done this when your contemporaries or
other people you respect what have we
learned about those European years where
we didn't have as much of this kind of
food where it was more market and the
bizarre like what's that data [ __ ] like
what is so clear on people who eat
traditional diets live a lot longer they
feel better there's less obesity explain
that I mean it didn't come from a
factory it came from a farm it's pretty
simple people ate real food grown in
real soil I mean if you eat broccoli
today it's got 50% less nutrients and it
did 50 years ago in 1970 when I was 10
years old because of how we grow the
food and the depletion of the soil so we
get to period so I always say where
could I buy broccoli that is as good as
the ten year old you got you can go to
your local farmers market maybe find
someone who's got an organic or agender
farm it's actually in rich soil because
the soil is what makes the food healthy
it's what makes it taste good I mean I'm
just having dinner with a friend who
would just come back from Rwanda said
the soil was amazing you know 80% of the
people are farmers their subsistence
farmers the flavors the juices that the
colors were so amazing because it was
actually food that was not industrial
food which is what most of us eat in the
world now everybody's listening not
watching just a fun fact when he asked
me how old did you think I was there was
a really smart reason he asked that I
went to even a little bit high because I
knew what he was trying to do if you're
somebody let me give the three people
that might go with this he looks [ __ ]
phenomenal and so maybe one of the you
know a lot of you are vain [ __ ] and
like if you don't like all the other
stuff like about the environment or life
or anything else and you just want to
look better for longer there's that well
there's that yeah true i mean III
I wanna 320 my friend David asked me
once left 180 I'm not sure about that
yet we'll see but but I did my my little
120 at least my biological age I'm 60 is
39 is it true
yes I checked my telomeres my biological
age is 39 did all this could eating give
you really pretty eyes too or that was
just like I think I was born with I
don't know in my other skelter nature
and I use it to try to find different
insights because listen for everybody's
mad at me for cutting off the great dr.
Mark Hyman good news he does 800 [ __ ]
other podcasts and they all have the
same structure and you can go listen to
that in my great to find different
angles to great insights what didn't we
touch on that you'd like to hit on
before we get out of here
oh gosh I just I just want people to
understand that well you know it's sort
of like whether you mentioned Nazi
Germany you know imagine imagine a
Holocaust of people dying every year and
we're just not paying attention already
freaked out about coronavirus right I
want you know a night and I love you for
this key I mean like 11 million people
here I think that's conservative and
we're asleep it's like we were like the
Jews in Nazi Germany yep
when they marched into Poland where my
ancestors were shot to death in their
home and in concentration camps we're
like that and we we don't believe that
this is happening and we're sort of in
this dark space and visibility and I
just hope that people wake up to
understand that they have power to
change this that this is not a joke this
is not a dress rehearsal that are our
own personal interests are at stake our
ability to thrive and have healthy lives
and our families to be healthy and not
have you know them ridden by chronic
disease and that and the plan and I hate
to say it but we live in this thing and
there's you know if you look from space
there's no borders anywhere I mean I
literally was sitting with a guy two
days ago on a couch who was the minister
tourism for Tahiti and he said they are
aggressively strategizing building and
designing floating cities because in a
few years their entire countries are
gonna be underwater like this is real
guys and Miami Miami's got octopus in
the parking lots Miami yeah Miami so you
know weirdly happy about cuz [ __ ] the
Dolphins when Miami goes underwater that
should be two automatic jet wins the
NFL's listening got too much light on a
serious conversation but yeah that'd be
good I'm happy about that I'll tell I
want to be to an hour yeah you know no
but really I mean it's fun right because
again the reason I bring that up is a a
little bit for the Jets joke for my fans
and really when I say my fans I mean me
I just wanted to make that joke be much
more importantly like you know we're
very insular a lot of people listening
don't have passports I've never been
like you don't need to he D it's called
Miami yeah you've been to Miami yeah and
that's that's where I'm going a little
bit with John going to war yeah the
thing that is very clear to me
historically yeah is how do we make this
selfish yeah you're right you're right
and what's interesting is your subject
should not be as hard as other things no
this one's pretty no it's good you want
to live longer that seems selfish but
for some reason it's not connecting to
the level that I think it should as
somebody who's actually living that so
I'm like well I think the understanding
I mean in medicine there's very medicine
there's very little understanding that
food is the biggest cause of these
chronic diseases and it's the cure and I
think most people don't hear from their
doctors they don't realize oh I have
diabetes I have heart failure I have
autoimmune diseases I have chronic
digestive issues I have headaches and
migraines and yeah this and that and
other thing I may think oh this is just
what I got no it's guaranteed most of it
is caused by our crappy diet so don't
eat like for all the basic guys and gals
like me to wrap up don't eat things from
factories yeah that's good what if it
was made in a plant don't eat it if it
was grown in a plant you can eat it
that's your little you have that do you
have that hoodie you have a hoodie that
says oh that's from
I have another simple one if you believe
in God or nature if you don't believe in
God ask yourself a question everybody
needs something did God make this or did
man make this did God make a Twinkie no
did he make an avocado yeah but an
avocado potentially so much shittier so
there's like a wise and told me the
broccolis [ __ ] I wanna get back to a
better food system to grow better food
and so better than its so bad like I'm
lucky left to live in New York City and
back to your story of like two buses
that's hard but the far majority people
listening right now have options so for
us that do have options how do we need
to think about the thing I'm like yeah
god made that banana but that's it but
likley let me tell you when I actually
first started paying attention I'm like
out of nowhere a decade ago I'm like I
don't remember blueberries being this
big
yeah like when Barry Bonds and McGwire
started hitting homers I'm like you know
these [ __ ] blueberries are biddies
[ __ ] yeah must be taking steroids 100%
about that within the broccoli and the
blueberries that look like well you know
most of our crops are gone we we had
Larry hundreds and hundreds of species
of plants we had hundreds of apples of
varieties of apples now there's
basically three plants that we eat corn
wheat and soy that's sixty percent of
our calories and there's about 12 plants
that make up the rest of our diet and
most of those are grown in ways that are
for shelf-stable or for transport or for
you know size and not for flavor and not
from nutrition and not for for actually
health and I think that's why we're
seeing this sort of our depleted diet
and when you go to a foreign country you
go to their markets and you see stuff
you never saw you see cuz it look so
strange see incredible flavors I mean
even like the fingerling potato potatoes
David Boulet who's a chef here in New
York brought them from Peru people like
what is this but it turned out to be so
much more nutritious so much more
flavorful or this is going right war
like I hear you talking right now I'm
like [ __ ] I hope this doesn't happen
during my watch but like if this is how
it's gonna be this is gonna be a
resource war game and we're gonna be
like you know this is just what happens
yeah than gold and like I mean honestly
you're right you're right I mean we have
no I you have no idea how bad it is
because the way we're growing food is
destroying our ability to grow food why
because it causes climate change
degrades the soil and so the food and
security issues are gonna be huge and
then the climate refugees the the Syrian
refugee crisis as a million Syrian
refugees we're talking according to un
200 million to a billion climate
refugees within a few years like what
are we gonna do with all those people
that's gonna create political
instability that's gonna cause war it's
gonna cause violence I mean they're
coming over here I mean it we've got to
figure this out final point if people
are buying what you're putting down is
this I'm a simple man
is this like hey get a little more
educated on how you can eat from farms
or things like yeah there's really
something that's on a food fix book.com
there's a downloadable action guide okay
all the 20 actions you can take to make
a difference for yourself in your food
system and if you want to get
politically involved how to do that what
to advocate for if you if you want to go
in your schools and get your school's
eating healthier food how to do that if
you want to go to your local community
you know civil city council and say you
know we want to compost the ordinance in
our town there's simple things you can
do as individuals that make a huge
difference and we're seeing it I mean
when I saw the King ad I was like yes
you know what about we are winning fast
it was a whole nother topic but give me
your 12 okay so into that yes yes so do
you fast I do so well I I do maybe an
actual hold a fast maybe once a month
okay but I usually do what we call time
restricted eating which is with you
within an eight hour window
okay so I'll sort of eat dinner finished
by 7:00 you can eat by 11:00 the next
day it's not that hard and what that
does is it's an activates all the repair
and healing mechanisms in your body that
slow aging that lose belly fat that
build muscle that increase your
cognitive function that build bone
density that reduce inflammation that
activate your antioxidant systems so
it's a powerful tool that is not about
changing what you eat but changing when
you eat so the 11:30 p.m. hardcore big
dinner at 6:00 a.m. doughnut bad news
bad news
the only trans before
and make sure you you know you give
yourself I mean why they call it
breakfast break fast but if we all eat
all night long then even wake up we're
not doing that our bodies this is the
best meal of day the time restricted
eating any time you can do it from 6:00
in the morning like missions done till
2:00 in the afternoon just my [ __ ]
day you do whatever you want
doctor thank you so much thank you
you